كان الجزء من سوريا الذي اختار أبو بكر
البغدادي الاختباء فيه
خيارًا استثنائيًا في أعمق
معقل لداعش هو المنافس الأيديولوجي
للقاعدة ويبدو أيضًا بعيدًا إلى حد ما
ولكنه أيضًا دافع جيدًا عن
الصور المذهلة لتدمير هذا
المركب.  التي حصلنا
عليها كانت أصعب الأماكن للدخول
إليها وأصعب تخمين أنه سيختبئ
فيها هو كل ما تبقى من المكان
الذي اختبأ فيه أكثر المطلوبين في العالم على الأرجح لأسابيع
الكثير من القيمة الاستخبارية التي تم نقلها
إلى أنقاض  تم توضيح
الغارات الجوية المتكررة من قبل
الإسلاميين الذين يسيطرون على المنطقة ، وقد
حصلنا على هذه الصور من مصور محلي
قادر على العمل في منطقة
ستكون فيها القاعدة قوية ولكن حيث
يتم قصف المدنيين في أماكن أخرى
كثيرًا حتى تكون الحياة طبيعية.
القتلى هنا تم جمعهم
وسحبهم من القذائف المتناثرة في المنطقة ربما
من المروحيات الثماني التي وصلت إلى
هنا في جوف الليل قبل أن
فجرت الكوماندوز ثقوبًا في المنطقة.
جدران التل تم إيقاظ أحمد
قبل الساعة 11 مساءً بقليل.  بالتوقيت المحلي
وصُدمت لرؤية طائرات الهليكوبتر تحلق
على ارتفاع حوالي 150 مترًا بعد تسعين دقيقة
، أعقب انفجار بعض
المطرقات المليئة بالملل والقرنية ، ساعة متر ووتش كيلو الأم
تشعر بملطخة شبيب أكويلا المعتوه ، تصفيق
لطيفة ،
رواية مثيرة يمكن غسلها كثيرًا كما استحوذت أسادا على
السيطرة عن طريق البالون  لا أحد يستطيع أن يشاهده وهو
يصرح عن عمد بإطلاق أي ذريعة في
مكان ما تحت هذا الغبار ، وهو النفق
حيث قال الرئيس دونالد ترامب إن
بغداد فجر نفسه وقتل
أطفاله الثلاثة معه ، ولكن بحلول الفجر ،
لم يكن هناك سوى القليل
لالتقاط ابن أبي ووالده.  عابرة مثل
ظهوره في العالم ، فقد سبه
بالعنف المتطرف